als Foundation habe ich jetzt hier die
naturware Foundation und da braucht ihr
wirklich nur eine Pumpspender davon und
streicht das ganze mit einem Pinsel
einfach von der Nasenspitze hin übers
ganze Gesicht ein bisschen Concealer
noch unter die Augen bisschen als
Highlight auf die Nase und auch über die
Lippe und kurz verteilen mit dem losen
Puder könnt ihr jetzt noch euer Make-up
fixieren und habt eben ein schönes
mattes Finish für etwas Farbe und
frischem Gesicht habe ich hier mein
Bronzer und Blush also das sind 1
Produkt das benutze ich tatsächlich die
ganze Zeit jetzt fehlt nur noch mein
Mascara da tusche ich immer erst die
unteren Wimpern und dann die oberen dann
verschmiert auch nix jetzt noch einen
leichten Rosette und auf die Lippen dann
nehme ich jetzt einen Lipliner und das
ganze wird dann abgerundet mit dem
lipoint und zum Schluss nehme ich hier
noch meine rosenspray das erfrischt mein
Gesicht und fixiert eben auch
gleichzeitig mein Make-up und das ist
mein Sommerlook schreibt mir gerne mal
in die Kommentare wie er euch gefällt